when experiencing any form of mental
distress or illness the world can become
a very lonely place we can fall into
damaging ways to cope but it may feel
like the only way for relief I struggled
mainly with depression and self harm to
cope I was terrified people would be
angry and judge me if I told them I
found hope when I met people that had
been where I had been and were on the
road to recovery I suddenly felt I
wasn't so alone that things could be
better I did experience some abuse from
a few people who found out but it is
because of a deeply ingrained stigma in
today's society we need to eradicate
this stigma because if people are too
scared to speak out it will only get
worse we need to be patient
understanding and compassionate it
doesn't matter what your age gender or
background is you don't have to suffer
in silence it is not a sign of weakness
to reach out for help there will be
someone out there who can make all the
difference in helping with recovery
you